coronavirus knows no boundaries that
makes it even harder to fight in the
palestinian territories which are
pockmarked with borders and checkpoints
then there's all the misinformation
about covet 19 and the vaccines
still the vaccination rate in the west
bank and gaza is now around 50 percent
vaccination has become easy
[Music]
most vaccination centers are overcrowded
with a very high influx of people
officials say a vaccine mandate for
civil servants has helped push the rate
higher
[Music]
i'm ben fazoulen the pandemic is adding
another layer of difficulty to life in
gaza because it's taken so long to get
that vaccine drive going hospitals are
strained the health system was already
in a mess the economy too
here's our correspondent tanya kremer
from gaza city
here in the center of gaza city in
alvarde street workers are still
clearing the rubble of a building
destroyed in the conflict between israel
and hamas in may one of the several
continuing crises
a few blocks away dr shady award and his
team have been fighting the coronavirus
pandemic at gaza's largest hospital
al-shifa hospital
this ward is dedicated to testing and
treating patients suspected of having a
covet 19 infection while the number of
seriously ill patients has slightly
decreased in recent days infection rates
remain high
we used to categorize these cases in
people who could be sent home and
treated at home
and cases who were admitted and treated
in hospital
some were sent to intensive care
we've been in this latest wave of the
pandemic for a month
it's been the biggest and most intense
wave since the beginning of the pandemic
here in gaza
the staff are exhausted the doctor says
over
500 people have died of covet 19 in gaza
the pandemic has further strained an
already weak health system and dire
economy
the small territory ruled by the
militant group hamas has been
effectively cut off by israel and egypt
for the past decade
although scarce in the beginning
vaccines have become increasingly
available but more people need to take
them still we will work with the
community in engagement with the
community and help the authorities here
to spread the facts and the safety of
the vaccine and to encourage people to
get the vaccine at the moment gaza
has reached 40 percent of vaccination
among the targeted population
roughly 1.2 million out of gaza's 2
million inhabitants are eligible to get
a job at a vaccination center like this
one
authorities have made vaccinations
mandatory for certain categories of
people such as those working with the
public however reactions are mixed
there are a lot of problems
it's very crowded
there is a lot of mixing in the
workplace in schools
among students
even with the
our elderly is very closely linked so
vaccination is very important
i took the first and second dose of the
sputnik vaccine and now they've sent us
the third dose
here people are generally not that
concerned about taking precautionary
measures they don't care about corona
that much anymore i feel that people are
just going along with things so covert
is not affecting them like it did before
maybe the most important thing is the
economic situation
while the pandemic continues to weigh on
daily life it is just one of the several
ongoing crises people have to deal with
in gaza
and the vaccination rate is even higher
since tanya filed that report for us
let's talk about the difference though
between the vaccination rates in israel
and the palestinian territories with
hassan james
he joins us from urban in jordan
tell us about this big gap between the
two can can you explain that to our
viewers
yes you know palestinian ministry of
health
have acknowledged that the capacity to
contain the spread of kobe 19 is limited
by ongoing and pre-existing
shortages in a health care system
including
medication disposable equipment and if
we look uh to the statistics of
vaccination rate among regional
countries we see that palestine have
similar uh uh uh vaccination rate to
those countries such as jordan lebanon
and kuwait you know recently from
mid-august until now vaccination rate
has been increasing because you know
people want to go back to to work to
normal life to universities i think you
know we can we can't uh compare well
occupied healthcare systems you know
having difficulties uh even those well
occupied a health system have having
difficulties handling this crisis so
imagine how a fragile health system and
occupied uh territories uh to to suffer
from this crisis so i think uh the one
fact which is the inequality of
provision of medicare surface vaccine
issue are a small part of a big and
complex story
so you put it more down to a lacking
health care system rather than
the palestinian territories or israel
playing politics here um why then is the
system so bad
for palestinians
you know um uh the the healthcare system
in palestine you know have faced many
unique challenges during the pandemic
israeli the main challenge is the
israeli control over the border
restrictions of movement between
districts the geographical separation
between west bank and gaza you know add
to these difficulties financial crisis
and limited resources for the
palestinian authority so we don't have
capacity you know to buy vaccines we
need we need to wait until uh donation
for example from kovic's initiative to
to uh
to give us the vaccines
in addition to that uh pre-existing
stressors to the health system
shortages of health worker and
community resistance to the reality of
pandemic and add to all of this
you know what has been mentioned in
4th geneva
convention that the occupying power you
know uh has to ensure and take
prophylactic and preventatives necessary
to control you know the spread of
contagious and epidemics and occupying
territories without pious
exactly you you just brought up israel's
responsibility according to
international treaties there and you
also mentioned kovacs but what about
israel's supply of vaccines does does it
have a surplus uh part of which is going
to the palestinians
you know my direct answer to this is no
they tried to sell us
near expired lots but the deal was
cancelled you know we are the
palestinian have the right to have valid
vaccine you know people are not lining
up a friend of uh clinics you know we
have a challenge to convince people to
take the vaccine you know so we need a
valid vaccine so we have more
flexibility you know to transport those
vaccines and store them
that's it
okay
thank you very much for being on the
show today
well there's been so much focus
throughout this pandemic on the
prevention of covert 19 and vaccines
treatment is just as important question
for derek williams
if i get covet 19 what treatments are
available
treatments for covet 19 can be roughly
broken down into two categories the
first
encompasses drugs that are meant to be
given at earlier stages of the disease
to keep it from getting any worse
they include what are called monoclonal
antibodies often called mabs
which are antibodies made not by the
body
but in a bioreactor
several different types have been
approved for emergency use in in a
number of countries but maps are
expensive to manufacture
then there's convalescent plasma it's a
lot cheaper
because the antibodies in it don't have
to be manufactured
they come from the blood of people who
have recovered from covid
the only problem is is that several
important studies have shown that
convalescent plasma has at best a very
limited impact on disease progression
many healthcare authorities
now limit its use or have stopped using
it entirely then there are antivirals
which also need to be given early
generally in symptomatic disease to have
a really positive effect by by
interfering with viral replication they
help reduce viral load which gives
basically your immune system some time
to catch up
the best known antiviral is rem
deservier which has been used to treat
covid
since the early days of the pandemic but
its effectiveness is also hotly debated
and it has a big drawback which is that
it has to be administered
by an iv in a medical setting
now that's not the case for a promising
new antiviral called
malnupiravir which has yet to be
approved
it can be taken in pill form by patients
at home
finally
there are drugs given to late stage
patients with serious illness the most
widely used of those
is called dexamethasone it's an
anti-inflammatory steroid that's
administered
to calm a patient's immune response when
it's spiraled out of control
and is doing more harm than good
[Music]
you